Dead Island 2 is getting closer and
closer to release and today we got a 15
minute gameplay dump the video is a mix
of gruesome combat location exploration
tiny slices of story and dialogue plus a
look at the Game's new skill cards these
collectible items can be scavenged off
the body of zombies found in hidden
locations all over LA or gained from
Simply leveling up but they aren't just
to look at skill cards can be equipped
to Grant you special abilities for the
upper hand in combat there is a Dodge
and a block card that both if time dwell
can stun enemies and help you regain
your stamina a war cry card that can
weaken nearby enemies and boost the
toughness of you and your squad and a
dropkick card that gives you the ability
to do just that there is currently no
mention of how many skill cards there
are in the game but the good news is
that a majority of them can be used by
all six of the game's playable
characters and what makes this system
even more exciting is that the abilities
of each card in your deck can be
combined for some some cool results some
examples include combining Dash strike
with hammer fist or ground pound with
flare-up and Quake Dead Island 2
releases April 21st and one week later
we're getting Star Wars Jedi Survivor
what an awesome month and even though
the Fallen order sequel hasn't been
released yet the game's director
stegosmussen has already expressed his
desire to make the game franchise a
Trilogy As musin Told IGN quote we had a
pretty decent idea of the time frame we
wanted Survivor to take place what the
stakes were going to be what the tone of
the game was going to be what cow was
going to be up against and how the crew
was going to factor into that and
there's ideas of what we can do beyond
that as well Jeff Grubb of gamespot's
sister side Giant Bomb added on Twitter
that quote the Assumption among the team
I've heard is that as long as Survivor
does fine they will begin working on
another Jedi game end quote and in my
opinion that means the third game is
definitely happening the first game did
well commercially and critically and
Survivor is releasing a whole two weeks
ahead of Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom so even if those audiences
overlap and they do in my case Survivor
has two weeks to thrive on its own
before link completely overshadows it
and dominates the internet Survivor
would have had even more time to shine
but remember back in January the game
was delayed out of its original March
release but if you need something to
play immediately and you want to give to
a good cause check out the turkey Syria
earthquake Humble Bundle this collection
of items has standouts like Gotham
Knights ghost Runner XCOM 2 Payday 2 and
67 others for just a thirty dollar
donation you'll also get System Shock
enhanced Edition and System Shock 2 and
with the System Shock remake currently
slated for release this month it's the
perfect time to revisit those classics
all the games are redeemable on Steam in
the comments and let me know your
favorite zombie game or your favorite
zombie movie and I'll see you tomorrow
thank you